Good morning,
my name is Akira Tendo. I'm
on the set of a production company where I admire the glamorous industry. I'm filled
with dreams, hopes, and expectations.
But
as long as I'm not urinating blood, I'm second-rate. Part of my
job is to make a hole in my stomach.  It's my house, it's this, it's
black.The one who changed my life is
[Music]
Zombie.I don't know what to do,
but if things keep going like this, I could
send them to work.But I do
n't have to go to work from today.Why is this
person like this?  Is he still alive? Please
entertain me
to the fullest. You don't have to go first.
[Music]
100 Things I Want to Do Before I Become a Zombie
Broadcast starts in July 2023